as millions of Americans are forced to
stay home a growing number of them are
choosing to adopt or foster a pet it is
a good time the ASPCA says nearly 70
percent increase that's what they're
counting and the number of animals going
into foster homes in New York and Los
Angeles that's compared to this very
same time last year
CBS this morning Saturday co-host Dana
Jacobson shows us how Americans are
stepping up to help animal shelters and
she's got a cute pup there Dana good
morning and good morning this is
Berkeley did not seem right to do this
story without my rescue who I'm bribing
with cheese right now actually you know
in these trying times that stories about
animals like Berkeley that really are
one of the bright spots if you think
about it
these animals finding homes in uncertain
times and in exchange they bring comfort
and calm to all of those who open their
doors and their hearts as schools in
Minnesota closed eight-year-old Ridley's
amudha and his sister's 10 year old Mila
and 12 year old Tegan began begging for
a puppy and with mom now also working
from home the time was right to adopt
four month-old Gomer
so go her I have to say has brought so
much laughter and joy into our family
and he's really such a positive force
during the super crazy time were
honestly so little of what we
experienced every day feels normal these
uncertain times have seen shelters
filling up but it's also brought an
outpouring of people looking to help one
shelter pup found a forever home when
his face was put on a pizza box they
can't see their friends so I think
having this loving pet showering them
with love and making wet kisses
really just helps them get grounded I
think with California on lockdown all
seven Animal Care and Control centers in
LA County are by appointment only
it may seem like you know that we're
closed
and adoptions are not happening but they
are happening we have about 300 animals
that includes you know dogs cats we have
Turtles
Alex shivers nonprofit I stand with my
pack works closely with California
shelters to find homes for animals last
week she placed 58 with Foster's we
rescued puppies that are bottle feeding
right now they were surrendered to the
shelter without their mother we kind of
had an hour to figure everything out
everybody wants to foster right now
which is absolutely amazing
but Schiffer says fostering has its own
challenges to help she's offering free
online classes with trainers these
animals when you get take them to your
home they're not gonna be housebroken
there there's gonna be a lot of
different issues that you will have to
deal with and be patient and ask for
help
lucky dog rescue in Washington DC is
answering the call from shelters across
the country this van arrived from South
Carolina with 84 animals on board over
half went straight to adoptive homes and
in the end if you save a dog and if a
family or a person ends up with this dog
in their lives or a cat it's really an
amazing thing it is and so having an
animal having that friend that warm body
next to you
it makes things feel better just ask Liz
amudha kids sometimes when we're sad we
tend to like just black everything out
and he's just always friendly and likes
to snuggle trust me they make things
better this Berkeley guy is my
everything right now and they're even
offering incentives if you're thinking
about getting an animal get this Tony
Bush beer Bush comm slash foster dogs
you can get up to three months of beer
for up to 500 people if you adopt from
Midwest animal rescue
- very good very good you know I hope
people keep it up and they get that free
beer in the process or 50% off you know
not totally free all right Dana keep
petting that pup and feeding them cheese